it's titanfall we've got Jeff Gerstmann
from the giant bomb com hello you
reviewed this video game I believe well
yeah sort of yeah in the works on it oh
yeah I've written most of what I'm going
to write about it and then kind of
keeping an eye on it today see how the
servers do before I kind of throw score
on it awesome i'm chris waters reviewed
it for gamespot com sure did you guys
been playing a side of the bunch cut
corners not me that's right yeah now put
a score on it done review out of the way
he trusted that's what those service
stay upright yeah service have they been
through stay out there stayed up there
good i'm getting into the bathroom Adele
gasket ball we did a live quick look a
little bit earlier today and basically
got dropped out of three or four xbox
matches I had a couple over the weekend
that's kind of dropped out but i guess
it was pre-release like yeah yeah the
servers were a little shaky until until
last night then they were shaky proper
hmm and then I don't know like there was
something on Twitter where the engineer
for respawn was saying like we're having
beers and was like eleven o'clock
alright I guess things are going well
but it seems like it's been mostly okay
yeah so people's fears can be alleviated
East for now we'll see you'll see I mean
you know we got about another three
hours until like prime time right us
time about 6pm here I figure we'll know
one way or the other I notice stinking
Europeans get on Friday I know it well
yeah I don't know what yeah Europe was
got it got out of there of course also
major nelson was just on twitter saying
like there are some people having
trouble logging into xbox live right
we're working on it and then also this
is not titanfall related please don't
blame the please buy the game please buy
the game you'll be able to play soon we
promise at this point I've gotten more
press releases from Microsoft than from
EA when it comes to titanfall arena and
Microsoft did not publish that game what
I'm saying huh I guess I guess that a
lot riding on game they are do you think
it'll sell out before we get into the
game do you think of the little actually
sell units of the console as you guys
know I mean if I was on the fence about
it yes I think it will sell xbox one's
just because like it's a game to be
excited about it's a game is getting a
huge amount of critical acclaim it's
also like a game in it one of the more
popular genres out there yeah I think it
yes you are right about all that but
also I feel I could say it's a genre
that is like has been on the decline
lately and
you could take that as like well people
are looking for something new and this
will drive them to it but I think people
are now a little bit suspect of
first-person shooters especially one
that is like by and large very call of
duty inspired yeah so that the phrase
the guys thrown around a lot is caught
up to you at mex you think it's it there
is some nugget of truth in that or sure
yeah but except it's call of duty with
mex and then also like Mirror's Edge
light free running you know while
running double jumps that's what that
actually i think is a much bigger deal
than the robots yeah the movement the
mobility and stuff like that because it
really changes the pace of the game the
range of the shooting you know can you
get it close to somebody is happening at
medium range all that sort of stuff
because you're just you can get up in
people's faces really really easily but
guys still go down when you shoot them
very quickly yeah it's an interesting
balance we're going to hop into the ad
the campaign multiplayer as it's called
which we've shown off a lot of the
multiplayer obviously in the in the beta
previously a couple of weeks ago and
that since the game is that it's kind of
easier to access these these servers
because there's more people playing and
Chris ki just give me there you go that
was it what you get for cutscenes into
that it that's it great that's what my
50 gigs is right here that Titan getting
a little gun down and like pre-scripted
that's a scripted thing but ago so that
there's something like that before each
of the you so much usually this guy in
the upper right corner saying like we're
on a mission to do something you keep
shooting guys while we do the cool stuff
so you put you play is it nine missions
with one side then line with the other
same line missions but from both sides
and is there any sort of resolution at
the end or you know they set they set a
stage for a sequel okay in you know
that's interesting best character of
2014 titanfall man yeah @chris hello
that gun seems to have Auto am honest
also this is like Jeff was saying that
you know the stuff people say about this
game similarity to call duty it's very
spot-on in terms of like most of like
almost all of the weapons just fill
those standard niches of assault rifle
SMG shotgun and there's not a lot of
them yeah you know there's just enough
to like cover every niche but this one
the smart pistol is
kind of the one that's that's different
you got the amp smart pistol which is on
a burn card so it's actually this guns
kind of crazy okay when you get the amp
version because normally to kill a pilot
which is a human player you have to wait
until this thing locks on three times
but with the amp version it just locks
on twice and okay quite quickly and then
you pull the trigger once it fires two
bullets into their head and they're dead
I feel like the burn cards were almost
like in Call of Duty you tend to get a
lot of weapon unlocks constantly they're
just feeding your weapons and whatnot
whereas I found like when you complete
the challenges and they see I felt like
I was getting more burn cards than
anything else to the point where I was
kind of sitting on what felt like a bit
20 or 30 of them but yeah as long as
you're playing well you will always have
enough burn cards one of those things
where like I had a run of bad matches
last night and woke up this morning I'd
like three okay like oh jeez because you
know you'll get them for successfully
evacuating or you get them from winning
a match I'll get them for you know
killing pilots and stuff like that so if
you're not playing particularly well you
will burn through burn you burn through
your brawn cards I like it if you've got
any questions for Chris and Jeff of bed
titanfall please send them in the game
spot shot or the twitch chat or tweet us
at gamespot and so 15 maps in this game
the single player seems like it's a you
know pretty light on on content and Jeff
how do you feel about this game as a is
a full price product because I know some
people have been yeah I've being a bit
well you know it's I look at two ways
you know if you take the bullet points
and add it all up I think it's light
compared to you know something like call
of duty yeah I mean there's no you know
there's no problemo you know it's like
it call duty for better whether you like
it or not it's three games in one in a
lot of ways three games that are of a
varying quality and all that sort of
stuff but still three games and what I
look at what I how I actually play call
of duty I only play the things that are
in titanfall okay team deathmatch
domination the multiplayer you know I
play all of it a little bit from
reviewing the game yeah playing through
the campaign but when it comes down to
it the stuff I actually want to play
that's the stuff that they focused on
you it's almost as if they had access to
a bunch of data about how people play
call of duty and then just made that but
who would have that data I don't know
it's hard
say a colon is good really and so a bit
so that then tape but you BA in some
ways did itself a disservice by putting
out that plants vs zombies game a couple
okay because that is a game that when
you look at you know it is also thin on
content but it at least has a horde mode
if something's a little bit different
and it's 40 bucks yeah so do you think
that that's where they're going to apply
to DLC when the modes rather than Maps
or I think they already come out so
they're doing Matson okay so you know I
and I think you have to do maps but I
would like to see them do modes but I
think the problem is the most they have
our damn you're identical new modes that
have been a call of duty and stuff like
that you know they and every shooter and
every shoe yeah like that mean captain
off flat I don't want to play CTF in a
game ever again ever again unless that
someone comes back to like hey you know
like we got three wave and we're
actually doing it right we're doing a
fall to that you know you know grappling
hook give me the stuff that a CTF should
actually have and for them to have like
five modes and then two of them be
basically identical they have attrition
here and pilot hunter and the only
difference is kind of the scoring yeah
that's a bummer no matter how you look
at it the end of the day it's like this
is the stuff that I would play when I
play call of duty but it's still hard to
you know look at it like well I mean
they're not really doing that much new
from a modes perspective and that sort
of thing like they've made a fascinating
twists on a call of duty style
first-person shooter I really enjoy it
like all this wall running stuff all the
mobility getting on the backs of the
titans like the crazy business you get
up to is is super fun but it's all kind
of thin at Chris you are more of a fan
of battlefield than the call of duty
series becomes the first person shooters
at you really enjoyed this game given in
my point on gamespot is this the sort of
game you think you're going to keep
playing post review or you kind of burnt
out on at the moon asked me once I've
done a day of three long live streams
for a game spot oh yeah no I think this
this is the kind of game that I see
myself playing a bunch in the future and
really it's down to
the way that mobility makes it feels so
different like yes this is you know the
way that you like you know a lot of it
is very similar to sort of cult like the
sprint speed the weapons the grenades so
many of these elements are that familiar
stuff and I mentioned that in the review
but mobility is such a like baseline
foundation for how you play a game and
how these things work that to me it just
it makes it it makes it a whole
different game a whole different
experience and they've made it very easy
to control like the wall running the
double jumps and stuff like that like
you don't need a whole lot of time to
get that stuff down and start doing some
really yeah creative things with it it
felt like in the first 15 20 minutes it
was sort of my eyes were open to how it
worked and then when I got the full game
some of the maps actually have these
sort of ridiculously obvious walls right
are often like come on there's a lot of
spot yeah I'll run from here to here
yeah for sure and it creates a situation
where like this game is full of like
it's great that this is on a console
that has like that whole game DVR thing
like yeah the xbox stuff because this
game when you are playing it well the
whole thing looks like one big highlight
reel yeah but you're just jumping
through windows and kicking people in
the face and jumping out of the window
and shoot three guys and jump it over
here making a robot falls guy like those
sequences are pretty amazing and you've
been playing the game for it yeah I
don't have a put in like 20 25 hours now
between the review and then kind of
checking the review against the real
retail version like I'm level 44 on
retail right now on xbox so at this
point like I'm really close to 50 I'll
probably hit the cap at some point yet
50 is the cap and then you like do
there's like a prestige yeah where it's
like hey I couldn't unlock all that
stuff again yeah and I might do that
there's an achievement for it so why not
put your team in school right now I kind
of lost track it's a hundred and fifty
two thousand dollars would be 1000 some
are over there but at this point I've
played a whole lot of titanfall in a
very short period of time yeah I will
have to play a little bit more to you
know kind of finish off the review stuff
and then almost with the 360 version
when that comes in
but we had a question just roll across
the screen there at like almost like
some sort of ninja I barely saw it is
there free for all a question from Chris
MC for 417 and nope would this game be
awful with free for all modes yeah I
mean be for all modes in call duty i
thought were a little weird to just for
farming XP OS but yeah yeah that's
really why that stuff was no i don't
think it really needs it cuz then also
like so there's another thing that the
whole grunt thing like how would that
work in free-for-all grunts are these AI
soldiers that spawn on to battle you'll
just make them everyone's enemy yeah
like unreal tournament any Morpheus just
spawn 64 bots in there and get your
rocket launcher as you you haven't
playing the game for quite a while
Jackie sort of saying that maybe it
might take some time off but in terms of
that like those bombastic moments that
highlight reel stuff is that's kind of
does it still ring true once you've
played it for that long like there's
definitely yeah I mean there were
moments last night and kind of playing
it as the servers were starting to
slowly crumble and yeah just definitely
getting up to shenanigans again it's one
of those things where once you have
really spent some time with the wall
running and then really spend some time
getting around the maps and learning
them like you can do some really stuff
there's like wall run to jump around the
corner of a building to keep wall
running jump up to the tile you like the
ways and get around it's really
impressive I this incidentally is
actually my least favorite map really
yeah i played this on sunday night and
managed to stay alive for three titan
falls on the roof and then the server
dropped and i almost put my xbox one
controller to tell ya I was it's just
it's a little too there's a little too
much inside stuff the outside areas i
think are too yeah they're really yeah
but at the same time stead like the
rooftops you have these huge long sight
lines there that's torn up I'm mostly
mean for titans yeah you know that this
is a good map for just like auto Titan
just drop it and
do whatever it's gonna do and I'm busy
inside capturing point sir yeah doing
real stuff I found it hard to find
people in this reduction are there any
maps that are sort of surfacing as the
favorites like dost just do stuff um
it's tough because I mean there's no way
to you know you can select mouth and
yeah I'll private you know there's no
custom matches yet they've talked about
patching that infirmary but that's not
an option so it's kind of hard to to see
I feel like I'm you know maybe I'm just
making this up maybe you can actually
because you played a lot of two but it's
Lagoon right the what the map at the
water mm-hmm how many times have you
seen that I don't think I saw that the
entire review event yeah I saw for the
first time yesterday on a live stream so
i saw that map once during the event i
think it's come up twice since i started
playing it yeah what I wonder like
that's that map with the water and stuff
the framerate can get pretty nasty there
I wonder if it's like weighted lower
than the other map I don't and also it's
it's got this weird like there are three
areas but the cores between them are
narrow and it's it just seems like not a
great mix of that pilot Titan space yeah
because I think of the best maps in this
game and the best part about the game is
the way that pilot combat in Titan
combat kind of intertwined like you're
in a Titan you can't disregard enemy
pilots you're in a you're a pilot you
can take potshots at Titan and be a huge
threat to them like it's the way those
systems combine that make it so so
vibrant and I think the maps that do
that well are ya are definitely the ones
that were they do really well with the
just the balance on on that pile of
Titan interaction you know like the the
Titans are not invincible they're kind
of fragile if you're lazy about keeping
them alive if you bring them into the
middle of a war zone you're probably
just immediate blown up so it's really
fun to get on rooftop with the the bank
launcher which launches like magnetic
grenades that oh I'm gonna attract
two-bit I'm just uh okay and let them
have it that way it does substantial
damage like it'sit's that's more fun for
me than actually piloting the Titans
month themselves it's funny I I have not
seen angel city once since I started
really it came I feel like it's come up
a ton oh really yeah came up during our
live stream earlier it's yeah and the
lagoon when I've only seen once as well
and that is where I've seen some
framerate stuff I've also seen it if you
like shoot glass panes really close have
either of you guys see that happen yeah
for me like the the big moment I had was
home and I can remember the name of the
map but it's got an indoor
area in the middle and we were playing
last titan standing so everyone spawns
in a titan have to keep their titans
alive first team running out of titans
loses the round everyone took their
titans and like basically like cram them
into this small room and started pulling
every trigger they call a rocket
grenades like a punch yes sire she opens
everywhere everything's happening all
over the place and at that point the
xbox just it was almost like it just
crumbled and the like there was a good
second or two where it was just like
here's a frame yeah here's another frame
here have one more frame for the road
when you like have you play old
first-person shooters and when that
happened it was like the best yes like
you announcing my dad's cute super
nintendo game yeah you thought like oh
they had to slow it down to make a look
so awesome is like no that's not that's
not how this happened that seems like
it's within the realms of like it's it
you wouldn't really complain that much
about that if it's happening in those
situations yeah I think for me it since
the frame rates kind of uneven
throughout you know like the moments
where it chugs like that like you know
few and far between it's more the kind
of overall there's some tearing in the
frame rates not outstanding but it's one
of the things where they're out there
you know the engineering side of
responds out there saying like hey we're
still working on this yeah so and may
actually change the resolution yeah who
knows if they can't get the frame rate
of like did work on that first I don't
raise the resolution yellow were it man
and it's the same like for me the the
framerate stuff has never you know aside
from this sort of the anomalous moments
of that that big sluggish stuff I it
doesn't really like as I'm moving
through the level as I'm trying to take
aim at piles like I never feel like I'm
hindered by that stuff yes not sort of
you know another screen between me and
the the action that I'm trying to get
involved in which is which is great but
I mean has that frame rates up in stuff
that you've noticed since we're like Oh
yesterday yeah i mean i mean i'm sure
people do want to show you a couple of
times yeah you know not not nothing as
bad as happened during that event but
clearly small butts were like oh geez
all right that's time for nine-point-oh
on gamespot com giantbomb.com probably a
four out probably four or five unless
the servers are on fire forever cool and
then it's like a zero out of five cuz a
lot of game
you